I think most people understand that life
is special but it's not always clear
what makes life special and different
from non-life such as stars planets and
and rocks so we believe that what makes
life so different from these things is
its persistence over over eons for
example some of the genes that we carry
is written in our DNA have been around
for billions of years some of them
almost unchanged the way that is
possible is because that information on
how to do certain things how to build
these bodies is written in an alphabet
this alphabet for DNA is known to be
nucleic acids but we believe that that's
not a universal property of all life the
only property that's universal is the
fact that there is information written
in an alphabet you can use alphabets
from any kinds of different chemicals
and in other planets somewhere in the
universe where there is lively we might
find the same phenomenon of persistence
but written with information in a
different alphabet so that the
universality of life is it's persistent
engendered by information encoded in an
alphabet that allows us to transmit the
information from generation to
generation for eons to come